Do I have enough of the delta-tocol triadols in the immune packs for my
tenitis? What are if all the detoxine triggered tenitis? Possibly that could be
the detoxine stress that could trigger tenitis. Tell you that right now because
what a stress do it attracts the vessels. So if you already have some plaque
you did the vessels on a terminal vessel, that's gonna make it worse. The
immune packs. So let me search that real quick and I forgot what's in there. So
that has that 80k it has delta-tocol triadols in the D that is in there. Baby,
baby that's enough. That's certainly a good supply for your heart. If you're
having conditions specific issues sometimes you want to ramp it up on the
delta-tocol triadols but I'm not saying that that is your tenitis issue. There is
also a tenitis program on the right if I'd suggest trying. We've had people
that said it helped.